(gentle music)
By protecting nature, recovery is possible.
If enough people start moving in the right direction,
we'll get there.
(gentle music)
Greetings, earthlings. Good to be with you.
Welcome to the podcast.
Dubbed "Her Deepness," my guest today
is an absolute living legend.
Her name is Sylvia Earle, and she's a marine botanist,
an oceanographer, a writer, a lecturer,
and one of the world's top experts
on ocean science and conservation.
Named the first hero for the planet
by Time Magazine, Sylvia has devoted all of her 85 years
to better understanding our oceans
and breaking glass ceilings along the way.
In addition to being one of the very first
National Geographic explorers and residents,
she also served as the first female chief scientist at NOAA,
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration.
She's also authored more than 20 books,
pioneered submersible engineering
and established this thing called Mission Blue,
which is an organization dedicated
to protecting marine areas identified as critical
to the health of the ocean
or, as she calls them, "Hope Spots."
You might have seen Sylvia in her appearance
in the recent documentary "Seaspiracy."
She also has a brand new book out entitled
"Ocean: a Global Odyssey".
This is what it looks like. It's an amazing book.
You gotta get it.
And she's here today for a conversation about many things,
the majesty of our oceans,
the tragedy of their precipitous decline
at the hands of humankind,
and the urgency that we all must marshal
for their preservation.
Sylvia is a gift.
Her a example sets the tone for us all.
I have so much admiration and respect for her.
It was an honor to spend time with her.
And my hope is that this one inspires you
into your own form of action and activism,
because ultimately it really does all come down to us.
So please hit that subscribe button
and enjoy my conversation with Her Deepness, Sylvia Earle.
Just at the outset, I wanna say I'm a long time admirer
of you and all the work that you've done.
It's really an honor to have you here today.
Well, thank you.
To talk about the beautiful mysteries of the deep,
the crucial importance that healthy oceans play
in the preservation of our interconnected world.
The decline in that health and what we all need to shoulder
in terms of responsibility to ensure its survival for us
and all the creatures with whom we share this planet.
Of course, all issues that you've devoted your life to.
But I think a good place to start would be,
I'm interested in hearing about your experience at COP26,
because I know you participated,
you did a panel with Al gore and John Carey.
There's a whole spectrum of opinions about
how productive that conference was.
What was your experience being there
and what did you take away from that
in terms of where we're at?
So what will be the disposition of our conversation?
You're gonna spread it far and wide, is that-
Far and wide.
As many people as possible to the best of my abilities.
Great.
So tell me what was it like being there
and what was that experience of COP26?
Did you leave it hopeful?
Did you leave it feeling like people aren't getting it?
What is your sense of where we're at?
The panel I attended with John Kerry
and Al Gore and others,
I think John started with a perception that,
although this was really on day two of COP26,
that was already a success because we were there talking,
we were gathered,
focused on a topic that many people are denying
even is a problem.
But nations had come together with the expectation
that they try to make some progress
and some progress was made, not nearly enough
to satisfy what some of us see as the need for speed,
scale up and speed up and to put nature front and center
often considered less important than techno fixes
that attract money because you can invest
in engineering solutions.
And when you look at the ocean,
that largely is regarded as free,
you can't make as much money out of saving
or solving the climate problem
if you're simply saving nature.
But shouldn't that not be the primary focus,
something that all of us can do,
even in your own backyard, be a part of the solution,
even in your own eating habits, be part of the solution.
If history tells us anything it's that humans don't seem
like they're very well wired to consider the long term
consequences of our actions, right?
Like our incentives seem to be misaligned
where we over index on short term gains
over what we're going to reap long-term.
And unless we can realign those incentives
and create systems that reward industry, people, et cetera,
for preservation and taking care
of these precious, delicate ecosystems.
I find myself despairing of our ability
to actually solve these problems.
And yet, if you ask people about what their hopes are
for the future and why about wanting
to have a better world, or at least a world as good
as what is now around for their children,
there is this almost universal desire
to make sure that your kids are going to be safe
and that you will be remembered in a favorable way,
not as a generation that has really lost the future,
cost the future for them.
But you're absolutely right.
That making the connection between your everyday actions
or even your semi long term actions will be reflected
in a better place for your kids.
And yet I think the positive side of all of this,
including the input and the outcome from COP26
is that we are armed with knowledge that not only did not,
but could not exist even 10 years ago,
let alone 50 years ago or earlier this,
the smartest people, whoever lived really did not,
and couldn't imagine what we now know
because of the computer technologies that enable us
to share information so quickly to see patterns,
to gather data and not just data points, but oh,
now I see this connects to that, connects to something else.
And for the first time, I think of this
as a sweet spot in time because of what we now know
that it's unprecedented, and also with the capacity to act
once we decide that it really is urgent.
And I think the one thing that was sad
about not being in front and center at the COP26 conference
was a real sense of urgency,
that to do what we're doing is if our lives depend on it.
I mean, we really took action rather quickly with COVID-19
because we realized our lives depend on it.
And it's true with climate even more comprehensively,
but it's less obvious.
Right.
Right, I was watching the Netflix documentary
"Mission Blue," your documentary last night.
And among the many
kind of very impactful points that it makes,
I think it's you, who said, you know,
"Whether the ocean is healthy or dying or dead,
it looks the same."
That's true.
It it's gonna look the same no matter what,
which makes it difficult for the average citizen
to connect with the urgency of the problem.
Or even the exceptional citizen, like scientists,
who look at the surface
and they've probe the upper level of the ocean,
much of the ocean is still yet to be seen,
let alone explored.
And if you don't know it, you don't know something,
it's difficult to care about it.
And we tend to make our calculations
based on the evidence we've got.
And here is most of the living space on the planet
below where divers go
and where most measurements have been made,
where most knowledge about the ocean
rests in the sunlight portion of the ocean.
Below that is where most of life on earth actually exists.
We're beginning to appreciate that even deep water currents
that were no not known until fairly recently
have a big role to play in climate.
They're not up there at the surface.
We know about the Gulf Stream. It's right there.
You can see it and measure it and taste it.
But what's underneath,
the currents flowing in the opposite direction,
and cold currents, and the whole interplay
of salinity and temperature and movement of water,
movement of animals, movement of life in the ocean
that shapes the nature of the planet as a whole.
And we're just beginning to appreciate
the magnitude of what that means.
And doesn't stop us from wanting to mine the deep sea.
It doesn't stop us from increasing transportation
on the surface, not just creating massive amounts of noise
that we now know has a shockingly powerful influence
on life in the ocean that we didn't appreciate 50 years ago
and many still don't.
But I, you know, being in the ocean as a diver
and hearing the sound of engines when they're roaring past,
and also looking at the churning of even an outward motor,
let alone the kind of power that is generated the churning,
the mixing, the disturbance
that we create in the water column,
we think of it as being just all one uniform system.
I mean, why would you think otherwise
looking at it from the surface?
But when you get into the surface
or when you lower instruments into the sea,
you can see how layered the ocean is.
Even when the surface looks fairly wavy and even turbulent,
many of those layers, density layers
with different salinity,
layers of life that are related to light and temperature.
I mean, we have significantly disrupted this harmony
without even knowing where to begin
to measure the consequences.
Well, there is this creeping acknowledgement
of how crucial ocean health is.
And yet, that kind of butts up against a lack of urgency
to do anything about it.
And at the same time,
so much of the ocean remains unexplored.
Isn't it something like only 5% of it is anything
that we even really have a grasp on?
So with that knowledge of understanding,
like how crucial its health is,
and yet this vast expanse of unexplored territory
that is just beneath us, seems rife for an influx
of interest and science and exploring
and greater understanding.
We're getting better about mapping the ocean,
but in the next 10 years, there's a concerted effort
on the part of nations organizations around the world
to have a consistent form of defining bathymetry.
Get a map of the ocean, where are the ups and downs,
where are the mountains and the valleys and the flat places
so that it can be accurately mapped,
at least as good as what we have
for the moon and Mars and Jupiter.
They're currently much better mapped
than our own ocean floor.
That's crazy.
I know, I know.
But from the bottom to the top, that's the ocean,
the wet part of the ocean,
and also the water that trickles down the cracks through,
in the bottom of the ocean, life persists.
We now know from a few samples
to at least two kilometers down.
So what exists beneath the bottom of the ocean?
It's still not terrestrial the way that we define life.
One of the greatest anomalies in the way
we look at life in the sea is that we think
of whatever is out there in a way totally different
from the way we view life on the land,
with the exception in recent years of whales and turtles
or fellow mammals, and to some extent, sea birds,
but there is a great concerted effort right now
to try to stem the loss of wildlife.
And one of the biggest problems
is the perverse trade in wildlife.
When we think of ivory, think of pangolins and their scales,
think of a host of wild...
That used to be, you think about egrets
that were really decimated to almost the point of extinction
because of their feathers,
and other wild birds similarly,
and some species have gone extinct
because we have favored them for food
or we have favored them for ornaments or whatever.
But what's missing right now in this discussion
about wildlife trade and wildlife loss,
including a major article in...
I don't remember whether Science or Nature,
I should remember,
but it was about vertebrate, the loss of vertebrates,
and the trade in vertebrates,
and the efforts that are being made to stem the loss.
And they're talking, of course, about mammals and birds,
even amphibians and reptiles,
but the largest group of vertebrates
was not even considered: fish.
Fish.
They are more diverse
than all of the other forms of vertebrates combined.
And yet we lump them together as, hmm, delicious seafood,
let's go get 'em, take them on an industrial scale,
measure them by the ton.
We don't even recognize tuna as individual animals.
We give authority through our laws to industrial fishers
to take them by the ton.
It takes a lot more small tuna
than a few bigger tuna to make a ton,
more lives lost in the process of making a ton.
But however you measure it,
we shouldn't be measuring wildlife as if they're products.
But they are.
Yeah, there seems to be an empathy gap
when it comes to fish because the human mind has trouble
connecting or finding some kind of commonality
with that living being,
but your work speaks very loudly to the contrary.
I hear you, and I say, yes, but this is learned behavior.
A child, and even me as a child,
when my brother was out with a fishing pole
and he caught this little fish,
it was in a freshwater lake,
and this fish was struggling for its life,
and my brother had a big smile on his face
because he caught a fish, and I looked at that fish
and I said, "Stop! Put it back!
It's in trouble. It's hurting."
You know, I could just feel the pain.
And I mean, as a kid, I didn't know
that I should be turning off those emotions,
turning off my empathy.
We teach kids that it's okay to kill fish.
We start it at really early age and celebrate
whether it's sport fishing or commercial fishing,
let alone on the large scale, industrial fishing.
That fish are, we're taught that they're different.
We're taught, don't worry,
they don't feel pain the way we do.
Yeah. We now understand they do feel pain.
Of course, they feel pain.
Yes, of course.
You know, your firsthand account of watching that,
I mean, anybody who's been fishing and has hooked a fish,
it's pretty obvious what's going on.
And one of the things that you boldly called for at COP26
was an end to commercial fishing.
Well, industrial fishing, large scale, factory trawlers,
factory long liners, whatever out in the high sea is.
And I start there because when you think about
what it is costing all of us to have
basically five nations disproportionately profiting,
even though they're subsidized,
it's a kind of a false kind of profit
given the way we account for our economy.
It's taking from all of us, if we have any interest
in the state of the world and our life support system.
The mark, those who buy the fish,
whether it's for fertilizer or for food,
for salmon or cows or picking chickens or pigs, or for us,
these are not free goods just available to be taken.
You know, we're talking million of tons,
of wild animals that are being swept out of the ocean,
that favor a few, and it's a cost to everyone.
Yeah, it's horrific the more that you learn
about this large scale industrial fishing,
the trawlers and what they do to the bottom of the ocean
and just the amount of catch and how much of it is discarded
for the few alongside, you know, the shark fin trade-
All of those things.
With blue fin tuna and all of that.
It just seems indefensible to me.
Well, we have seen, I've this in recent times,
increasing spotlight on industrial farming,
where again, animals are not treated as individuals,
really just treated as products,
chicken farms, pig farms, cattle, whatever it is,
they're just products.
And sometimes you find empathy in the people
who are working with them, but generally speaking,
we've lost that connection with those animals
that we consume and who they are...
We just think about them as what they are, not who they are.
And that somehow has changed the dynamic.
And we think of ourselves as being lofty, humane creatures,
different from all others in our ability to empathize
and to somehow live in a different kind of world
than the, quotes, animals.
But the more we look, the more we find
there's empathy with other creatures
and often it's lacking in our own species.
Yeah, I think that creating that level of empathy
only comes through exposure and education.
And I know that's a big piece of your advocacy
is creating greater excessive ability to the oceans,
getting people in submarines, getting people in scuba gear,
because once you've had a small taste or flavor
for the manner in which you've spent your life,
it will allow people to connect with a greater whole
in a way that they just don't in their daily lives.
Well, I think most egregious,
with respect to how we are now approaching ocean wildlife,
is the illusion, A, that it's healthy to eat ocean wildlife,
fish, generally, whether farmed or fresh,
there is this headline out there,
"Eat fish. It's good for you."
And the second one is that we to eat fish
because of food security.
And you hear numbers all over the place
about how many people actually either need
or rely on ocean life, wildlife for their,
and then you fill in the blanks,
is your primary source of protein,
for protein, for animal protein,
and then there are various numbers attached to these claims.
When you peel back the layers and ask the question
as a kid might, you know, do you really...
Are we talking about need or are we talking about choice?
Do we really need to strip the ocean of wildlife
to feed people all over the world?
People who have never eaten tuna before are now being told,
we have to have industrial fleets out in the ocean
because we need what the ocean provides as a source of food?
When you think it through, would we say the same thing
about wildlife on the land?
Do we need to eat wild birds, songbird, eagles, owls?
Do we need to eat lions and tigers and elephants?
Some people do. They call it Bush meat.
They really rely on wildlife in the places that they live.
And often there's an attitude of respect for that
and understanding that if you can work
within a system, take some.
But the people who are closest to nature realize,
if they take too many, then they're out of business,
they're out of groceries.
So where you find examples of harmony
between people who have lived a long time in a place
taking nutrition from the wild animals and plants,
they don't kill them all.
When the numbers get low, either they back off
or they lose the chance to have them in the future.
And we have so much to learn from wisdom
that has been acquired,
but we no longer really face up to it.
'Cause we've now got nearly 8 billion people to feed,
how are we going to do that?
I really get that.
But I also understand that we don't have to feed,
in fact, we cannot imagine feeding humans with wild animals.
We just can't.
And the idea that we can sustainably extract wildlife
by the ton from ocean systems
that have nothing in their history that has prepared them
for humans as predators, nothing to enable them to escape
the great swaths that were cutting
through these fine tuned food webs, the nutrient cycles.
It's amazing how we can just make assumptions
because it's convenient to do so
and perpetrate these claims without evidence.
Yeah. The food security issue is an interesting one.
I mean, certainly there are communities that rely on
in an indigenous way, that local fair
that the oceans and the waterways provide,
but the percentage of those populations are very small.
It's much more of an income security issue,
and we need to find new sources of income
that are not destroying the planet in this way.
And that's not easy to solve either.
But if we succeed in protecting the high seas,
that's half the world,
it's a pretty big chunk of the blue heart of the planet.
It's oxygen generation, it's carbon capture,
it's wildlife sanctity, if you will, safe haven
with the capacity, perhaps,
if we could at least extend protection
for the benefit of everyone and the global commons.
Like we have overall clean air policies
that sometimes are recognized around the world
as the logical thing to do.
If we want to have clean air to breathe,
these are the things you do.
If you want to have oxygen generation and carbon capture
on a mega scale by the natural systems
that have been doing this now, I mean,
for hundreds of millions of years,
then we need to back off the large scale extraction
of wildlife from the ocean,
just as we need to stop clear cutting old growth,
especially old growth forests.
Planting a trillion trees really doesn't cut it
if you're at the same time cutting a trillion old trees,
got a long way to catch up with a loss
of these old productive trees
when you just put a little sapling in its place.
Right.
So, over the course of only a few decades,
I mean, dating back to maybe 1950, in this era,
in which the conventional wisdom was essentially
that the ocean was an undepletable resource
that was more resilient than anything
that we could throw at it.
We've now learned that that's very much not the case.
We've lost something like 50% of our coral reefs.
We've seen mass underwater species extinction.
We have these algal blooms
and all of the kind of disastrous implications
of our developing world and the implications
that that's having on our ocean.
State the case for why ocean health is so critical.
I mean, you mentioned carbon capture
and how vital the oceans are in terms of that,
but why should we care?
Like why is this so crucial that we do everything
in our capacity to protect and preserve our ocean system?
When I was asked that question back in the '70s,
by a young woman reporting for an Australian publication,
it just flashed with me that, okay,
so you don't care about the ocean
because you don't eat fish, you don't swim,
people don't drink salt water.
If the ocean dried up tomorrow, why should you care?
I said, okay,
(Rich laughs)
you got it dry up the ocean, no ocean, what have you got?
Only about 3% of Earth's water is not ocean.
And that 3% is constantly being recharged by the ocean
as water evaporates up into the clouds
and falls back on the land and the sea.
It's the biggest storehouse of water.
Start with the water.
All life needs water, ourselves very much included.
The shorthand version of that is no blue, no green.
No ocean, no us.
So we're not gonna dry up the ocean tomorrow,
but let's say you just modify the ocean, warm the ocean,
make it a generator of more powerful storms
and more frequent storms,
make it a generator of sea level rise
because warm water takes more space than cold water.
And that's part of what we're seeing right now
is the expansion of the ocean.
Change the temperature to the ocean,
either make it colder or warmer, and you've altered
one of the most basic things that we take for granted,
the range of temperature
that is suitable for human existence.
And if it's just water, it doesn't work either.
It's the living ocean that makes earth habitable.
It's taken all preceding history
to develop this closely interacting system,
or systems in the ocean, living systems,
mostly built collaborations, of partnerships,
it's like a giant symphony and every piece has a place.
And what we have done in a remarkably short period of time
is to derail, upend, cut swaths through,
disrupt this amazing system
that they say has taken 4.5 billion years
actually to assemble, and literally about 4.5 decades
to significantly rip apart.
And we're doing it with our eyes open,
with a smile on our face, we have laws to reinforce it,
laws protecting shipping,
laws protecting industrial fishing,
laws actually giving subsidies to kill the ocean.
Yeah. The subsidies are a huge problem,
because they provide the underpinning
for all of these systems that are destroying.
I mean, one of the more heartbreaking scenes
in "Mission Blue" is when you travel out in the Coral Sea,
past the Great Barrier Reef and you drop in
on what was once just an epic reef system,
and it's completely dead.
And just seeing how you're so far out there
in the middle of nowhere and yet-
The middle of everywhere,
as I've heard one of us say.
Exactly. It's so heartbreaking.
And yet, you carry yourself with such conviction
and a level of hopefulness despite all of this evidence.
You were there many years of ago,
you've seen this evolution.
How do you hold onto that sense of hopefulness?
Well, during 2020, when I had to kind of,
like most of the rest of the world,
sit back and reflect on questions such as this,
you know, what reason is there to hope
in the face of so much that's so negative, wars, poverty,
hunger, conflict, you know, you could go on and list,
and certainly climate, and the loss of the diversity of life
loom large in my mind.
But at that time, I was also in the midst
of writing this big book for National Geographic.
We have it right here.
"Ocean: A Global Odyssey," right.
And although I had thought a lot about the question,
"What reason is there for hope?"
I really had a chance to dive in literally
what we now know about the ocean.
Takes time to sift through the latest explorations,
the latest experiments, the latest reflections,
the latest studies on, on where we are,
and also to reflect on what we don't know,
which is enormous.
You know, the more we know, the more we know we don't know.
I've just been seeing that all my life.
But we know enough right now to realize there are things
that can be done, positive things.
Every individual can take action
that together magnifies into a movement,
into a change of policy,
into a new way of thinking about food.
There's evidence that we have done this in the past
about smoking, about wearing a seatbelt, about,
you know, in overnight, when we realized
that our lives were threatened by a virus,
and it's not the first time, although for the first time
we could quickly identify what it was,
not so long ago, the existence of viruses was not known.
We didn't even know what bacteria were
not so long ago in human history.
And now we have this ability based and armed with knowledge
to turn around, and when we get it to change,
it took us longer with seatbelts and smoking,
and we got it with COVID-19,
we have to get it with climate change and realize
that by protecting nature, recovery is possible,
and there's evidence, and that's partly what I focused on
in my COVID year.
Where's the evidence? What do we know?
Okay, look at what we've done with whales.
When I was a kid, whalers were celebrated heroic characters
that would go out and brave the elements,
and whales were portrayed more as monsters
than as fellow citizens,
caring, intelligent beings that have language.
They have society. They have families.
That stick together as communities,
almost like moving cities that have liquid boundaries,
certainly with dolphins,
you can see that these great collections
of several hundred thousand individuals
that is like a city, and they stick together,
and they move through the ocean.
It's just as a moving city.
But they communicate, they have names.
Sperm whales have what they call a coda.
Each one has a name.
Orcas have for each other, for one another, names.
Dolphins, a signature whistle
that is learned when they first are born.
And it sticks with them for their whole life.
None of this was known when I was a kid.
And as people began to know whales as something more
than oil and meat, the attitude changed to save the whale.
Whales movement really began on my watch.
And by the 1980s was a voice so powerful,
that in 1986, a moratorium
on the commercial taking of whales was agreed upon
by the International Whaling Commission.
I served on the International Whaling Commission
for four years and watched this interplay
of different ways of looking at whales,
which was in the '80s and '90s still evolving.
Now there's such a really powerful, strong recognition
of the value of whales alive,
and I don't mean just for whale watching,
or the value that the International Monetary Fund
commissioned a study that was released in 2020
at the World Economic Forum that a whale alive
based on the carbon climate value is large enough,
so if you take all the whales together,
we're looking at at least a big trillion,
big T trillion dollars worth of carbon in the whales alive
versus a tiny fraction of that if you want whales dead.
And then it's only once, it'll decline every year
as you continue to kill them.
So reason for hope: there're more whales today
than there were when I was a child.
More reason for hope because we're looking
at other forms of life with dignity and respect.
And it isn't just about the money.
It's about this ethic of caring, kind of an ethic of living.
Yeah, look at all the religions in the world
and how valuable and important that is
to the lives of people globally through all of our history.
And it puts a real value on human life and our existence
and even other forms of life
that transcend dollars and cents.
Huh, having said that, look at what we do with tuna.
They have to be worth at least as much as whales for carbon.
And we don't have yet in our minds
the ethic of understanding or caring about them
for their intelligence, their relationships,
their community, their ability to navigate
over long distances with no roadmap or lunch,
except what they carry in their head
and what they carry in their bodies.
And we've disrupted the wisdom of tunas and cod
and other migratory animals
because we've broken those chains,
and it's not just bad news for them.
That means look at the carbon cycle,
look at the nutrient cycle, look at where the nitrogen
and phosphates and other nutrients
that these animals spread around in a way
that has created the planet that we now occupy,
that is favorable to us.
There are more sea turtles today than when I was a kid.
In the '50s, when I was just beginning to dive
as a young scientist, I traveled down to the Florida Keys
to go explore the shallow water,
the coral reef, the mangroves.
And along the way, there are big billboards,
I remember one place in particular called the Duck End,
"Turtle Steak," And they had a price tag on it,
going further to get to Key West,
and they had turtles in pens,
just waiting to be turned into turtle steak, in turtle soup.
It's on my watch, there were these animals
just being treated the way we treat most fish and shrimp
and squid and lobsters.
They're just things, they aren't to be treated
with a kind of dignity and respect.
We now do accord turtles with international agreements
and policies and programs
that really protect the nests of turtles,
protect turtles on their migrations,
laws against killing turtles, or in this country,
even handling a young turtle that is coming out of its nest
and making its way to the ocean.
It's illegal to pick one up.
I mean, we really have a different attitude,
and it's happened on my watch.
I've seen it happen.
So I know it's possible to change in a way
that will get us to a better place,
protecting any place, giving nature a break on the land,
national parks, wildlife reserves in the ocean,
places that are highly or fully protected.
And I don't include managed areas,
because they don't really work nearly as well,
in fact, often, not at all that what you see outside,
a managed area and inside,
sometimes it's hard to tell the difference,
but where you really say, no, we need to safeguard places
where everything is protected, everything.
Treat these as sacred places because we don't know
how to put them back together again once they're gone
and we need them to restore what's been lost.
We need them as models to be able to really imagine
what health looks like.
Imagine if all of the big Redwood trees had been cut
and all we had were saplings left.
Kids would grow up thinking
that's what Redwood trees look like.
These little stalks, not the giants
that are still there because people before I came along,
had the vision to be able to protect, safeguard
some of these great giants against the appetite for lumber.
We're still killing the great giants
despite what we now know.
But there is hope. There is hope.
Yeah, at least we recognize that on land
because we bear witness to it, and we've done, I guess,
an adequate job of carving out protected land masses
and creating national parks and the like,
and there is a very strong argument
that that's exactly what we should be doing
with our oceans and our waterways.
And that's a big piece of the Mission Blue mission
of creating these Hope Spots, right?
So talk a little bit about the Hope Spots
and what goes into that.
Well, I think for most of my life,
I've been a champion of protecting wild places
on the land and in the sea.
I worked with the national park system.
I love the idea that we can and do give back,
and it's not necessarily because we see what we now see
about our life depends on: protecting nature.
I think during the era of Teddy Roosevelt,
it was because these are beautiful places
that inspire us with,
and that basically we should protect them
because they really are great for recreation
and great for spiritual reasons, whatever the reason.
But now we know that there isn't self-interest
that really includes the aesthetic reasons,
but really goes beyond it,
that our existence really depends on taking care of nature.
The carbon capturing, oxygen generating,
planet stabilizing overall,
the shaping the chemistry of the planet in subtle
and sometimes not so subtle ways that favor us,
and for us to now be at a point where we can see it
and measure it and understand it,
all we have to do now is to get that knowledge incorporated
into our basic thinking and make decisions
that really will lead us to a better place.
So you have these, how many Hope Spots are there now?
There are nearly 140,
and new ones coming along all the time.
They're different from the other approaches
that I wholeheartedly applaud of identifying those areas
that are still intact, the last wild places, if you will.
National Geographic has a project
that I have applauded from the beginning, the Pristine Sea,
is where you identify places that are about as intact
as they are anywhere in the ocean.
And then you work diligently
to try to encourage protection for them
on a government level and have expeditions there
to celebrate and share knowledge,
which is also what we do with Mission Blue.
We work both at the highest government levels,
but we also work with communities on the ground.
As other organizations, World Wildlife, Nature Conservancy,
Conservation International, Wildlife Conservation Society,
a lot of big organizations,
but there are a lot of small ones too,
that really are working at both ends
from a bottom up, top down, as they say,
and everything in between to try to really encourage people
to do what they can locally,
and with Mission Blue what we're trying to do,
and I think we're showing some of success
to develop a network, a network of hope
of people who are connecting with their stories,
with their data.
We're working with Esri, the GIS data management enterprise
that's now 50 years old based here
where I am now and you are, in California,
that has really developed the technology
to get various kinds of information and layer them,
And they work with cities for city planning,
with governments to understand where's the best place
to put a hospital given what we now know
about the community, instead of just randomly saying,
oh, here's a piece of ground, let's put it there.
No, it's more thoughtful than that.
So with Mission Blue and Esri, to get a story map
to delineate, basically, here's the territory
we're talking about.
Here's who lives there,
I mean, in terms of the creatures who occupy that space.
Here are the images and we're are getting divers,
we were working directly with PADI, for example,
the Professional Association of Diving Instructors,
to encourage divers everywhere,
when they go out on a holiday
or they go out on whatever it is, take pictures.
And if it's in a Hope Spot, or even if it isn't,
maybe they can upload data in a related way
to show, "Here are my images of whale sharks."
And somewhere else people have taken pictures
of whale sharks.
Somebody else has taken pictures
of the same kinds of creatures elsewhere,
together you really get a database
around individual species, but also what makes a community?
What are the fish? What are the bryozoans?
What are the sponges? What are the corals?
Who lives here?
And can we see their faces?
And can we see them over time?
Some people are able to contribute information
that they've gathered over years,
even a lifetime, like Randy Wells,
who's a dolphin scientist in Sarasota, Florida,
who's been getting to know individual dolphins
over 50 years.
He's got names, he's got associations with families.
He knows the grandparents, the parents, the kids,
the grandkids, you know, this whole assembly of information.
Now putting that information into the Mission Blue website
so scientists can access,
that makes information of that sort accessible,
something to be celebrated and used in a more favorable way
than has been possible here before.
That's really beautiful.
And the community piece is so powerful.
It's not a situation in which you're lobbying government
to enact a simple policy that protects these areas.
It's really boots on the ground,
getting everybody who lives there involved,
integrated with this shared mission,
and they make the decision about this.
In the documentary, there's the test case of the community
on the Baja Peninsula-
Yeah, Cabo (indistinct).
Right, they transform what was once a fishing village,
ostensibly, into this ecotourism area and how-
You know, we can't claim (indistinct)
that the fishermen themselves did that,
but we can certainly celebrate it,
and encourage others to say, "Well, they did it.
Maybe we can too."
That finding other means of making a living
is certainly more secure and safer because as they depleted,
the local populations of fish around Cabo Pulmo,
they had to go further and further offshore.
And the fishermen were being lost at sea.
And it was partly that that inspired them to say,
"Enough already. Let's do something else."
Right, and we've seen what has happened
on the west coast of Africa or with Somalia and how,
when there's no more fish, they become pirates
in order to survive.
So there's all these implications down the stream.
Part of the reason their fish are gone
are because of the high seas, or even in the coastal waters
where European Union has allowed industrial fishing
to come into other countries, it's not just European Union,
but countries are giving licenses to other countries
to come in their own exclusive economic zones.
And it gets a little more complicated there
than in the high seas where we're really talking about
a small number of countries that are really doing
most of the taking in the high seas.
And it's also fraught with other issues of human slavery,
where people are sure really forced into labor
and stay at sea for sometimes years,
where human is not even valued, let alone the fish life.
So Ian Urbina has done a tremendous service to all of us
by documenting the life of fishermen
aboard these high seas industrial fleets.
Right. Now we're having to contend with the growth
and the rise of deep sea mining as well,
especially as EV batteries
and all these kind of precious minerals that we now need
to power our ways in a manner that feels
like it's off the T of oil and gas,
and yet also has this tragic effect on our ocean systems.
Right, and that's another matter
that I really took a deep dive into
during my year of reflection,
but it was not the first time I began looking
at the deep sea mining issues, going back to the 1970s,
when it first became known that these manganese nodules
could be commercially valuable
and Lockheed really took an interest and began investing
literally hundreds of millions of dollars
to explore the potential for going
like several miles underneath the surface of the ocean
and deploy instruments that could scoop them up
and return them to the surface.
And then do, at the time, it was thought
that at sea processing was the best way
to deal with the tailings,
because, hey, who cares in the ocean
if you bring those things ashore?
People will notice that it's a dirty business, really is,
and could cause problems.
But after a while, I mean, there was a hiatus.
It wasn't just Lockheed, nation...
Number of companies around the world really were tempted
to think of this as the next profitable thing.
And it was so much an issue that when the Law of the Sea
was being negotiated in the '80s, it was the key issue
that derailed the U.S. participation because of the idea
that the technology that, quotes, developed countries,
especially the U.S. have, were the only means
that would truly make it possible to mine the deep sea,
and that it seemed unfair for us to be able to go
and take from the deep sea without sharing anything
taken from the global commons in a more equitable way
with nations that did not have the technology,
or to have either technology transfer, which we resisted,
or to think of how you could share the profits in some way.
That was a show stopper, and it kind of still is.
It's the idea that other nations
that we would share our edge on technology and all the rest
so that it would be shared more globally or more equitably.
So we are not signatures...
We'll, we're signatures,
but we haven't ratified the Law of the Sea.
So we're the outliers right now.
Other nations are calling the shots
when it comes to deep sea mining.
We can go as observers and we certainly have influence.
And we certainly have money to invest in these countries
and companies that are being given leases
to mine the deep sea.
It's the biggest wildlife,
biggest land grab on the planet right now,
that is largely not even acknowledged by most people.
You know, ask anybody in a grocery store
or in a meeting anywhere,
what do you think about deep sea mining?
They say, "Huh? What?" (chuckles)
Yeah, I mean, I admit to not knowing
very much about it at all and was learning about it
just in preparing to speak to you today,
and it's rather alarming.
But there's no doubt there's so much we don't know
about the real nature of the processes
that happen within these manganese nodules.
What we do know is that they're alive.
They're formed gradually over long periods of time
by bacteria, microbes anyway, maybe archaea are involved,
but we know that bacteria are
that take the small amounts of these metals
and other materials out of the seawater and accumulate them,
starting with something like a sharks tooth
or the ear bone of a whale or a bit of shell,
something organic starts the process typically,
and these layers are formed over years.
So something the size of a walnut
may have taken 10,000 years.
Something the size of your fist,
or they often use a potato as a size,
potatoes come in all sizes,
so what are you talking about here?
But millions of years to get that big,
and they're still growing.
I've seen manganese nodules
literally the size of a football.
I don't know the age of that monster,
but I know it took a very long time
to get that chunk of living rock into being.
So, first of all, we now are really making an effort
to look at old growth systems, old growth forests,
coral reefs are old growth that takes a long time,
to get all the pieces together, not just the corals,
but the full assemblage of small, medium,
and large creatures that make up a coral reef
or a kelp forest.
We might succeed in some cases in planting coral,
planting mangroves, planting sea grasses,
but just as a forest is not just about the trees,
it's this whole integrated system.
And when you take anything out, you disrupt it.
So keeping these places intact in the deep sea
until we really know what's the carbon cycle like,
and is there a way that we could treat
the deep sea creatures as a library?
Could we sample a few and figure out
how do those bacteria extract out of sea water
these metals, these materials?
Is there a way that we could encourage them
to do more of that?
Could we analyze what is it that they are doing
that we might be able to understand
and cultivate in some way?
Isn't that a 21st century approach,
not a 15th century or 16th or 17th,
or even the 20th century approach
of let's just take this living system
that has taken hundreds or thousands
or millions of years to form and commodify it,
whether we're talking trees or Lewis and Clark expedition,
let's go take the animals we can find for their skins.
I mean, we celebrate that as a time of exploration,
but the motives were much like the deep sea mining,
let's go mine the value in the short term,
in short term value.
I'm also, during my reflective year
that continues on this year and beyond, the rest of my life,
to ask questions such as,
so how much longer might we be needing
what they call virgin sources of lithium, cobalt,
manganese, nickel, and a host of other smaller elements
for our batteries, for our computer age material?
We're getting much better really focusing on this circular,
what they call the circular economy, emulating nature.
There's no waste in nature, there isn't
when you think about it.
Where are the junk keeps out in the ocean
that aren't made by humans?
Everything that is generated by one organism
that is thought to be, you know, trash, a throwaway,
gets pounced on and used by another creature,
starting with that International Monetary Fund study
that looked at the value of whales, their carbon value...
One of the headlines at that world economic forum
was about whale poop, about how whales,
when they consume krill or small fish,
they put nutrients back that power
and really emphasize the power
on providing nutrients for the phytoplankton
that keeps that circle going,
phytoplankton to zooplankton to fish, to whales,
and around the circle goes.
You take any piece out
like we're taking krill out of Antarctica,
now we break those links.
Take the whales out, you break those links.
And the joy right now is being a 21st century human being
armed with knowledge, we can do better
than we have in the past.
We can recycle batteries that whatever make,
whether it's a car or a refrigerator or whatever,
think about where does it go once you're through with it,
in the timeframe that you're going to use this thing.
Packaging is one of the other issues.
Packaging should never just become waste.
We should figure out how to package our goods.
When we move them around in such a way
that this becomes another product, maybe other packaging
that's just happening in some scale now,
but suppose everybody did it.
Suppose it just became a way of life.
Suppose we had our cities, our supply chain figured out
so that we don't have to source new materials all the time,
everywhere every day for new things,
but making better things out of what used to be discarded.
Even just this week, I saw a study about how the lithium
taken from batteries that were, quotes, used up,
that when the lithium from those batteries is recovered
and used for new batteries, it's actually better
than raw materials taken on the ground.
Whatever happens in the course of processing,
makes them a better product for the next generation.
Yeah, it doesn't feel overly idealistic
to imagine a situation in which,
if you are going to be creating a product,
that part of that development cycle
considers the afterlife of the product.
And that you have created an infrastructure around,
whether it's recycling or repurposing all of those materials
in a responsible way.
And if it's gonna cost more as a result of that,
then it's gonna cost more, but-
But think about the real cost, the full cost.
That's part of our problem with how we treat
how our economic system currently is structured,
especially with wild animals and wild trees.
What is the accounting base of a live fish
swimming in the ocean?
Zero.
Takes on a value when we kill it,
because you can sell a dead fish.
Actually you can sell live fish too, one of the most,
but in a different sort of way
that fish taken out of the ocean alive,
sold for the pet trade or, I think,
probably one of the most successful aquaculture facilities
pound for pound is in raising fish for home aquariums.
But then you don't continue to take them out of the ocean.
You take a couple or maybe six or 10,
and you turn them into moms and dads
that create a lot of kids that never see the ocean,
but they see a lot of friendly faces,
admiring them as gorgeous creatures that they take care of
for the rest of their lives, however long they may be.
But the idea that, I kind of got off of our track,
but the idea that we don't value nature,
we think of trees, board feet of lumber,
or they're in the way, let's get rid of those trees.
There's a cost to burning them or cutting them,
so we can plant corn or tobacco or soybeans or cows,
that they're kind of in the way.
So they're not only not free, they're a problem.
That's been our habit over much of the planet.
So how do we flip that, Sylvia?
Start with the kids, but start with everybody.
The best hope, really, I can't despair,
because the knowledge is really there
and it's our superpower.
We have to match our superpower of knowing
with an equally important superpower of caring.
You have to want to take this knowledge
and consider that this is a time
of greatest opportunity ever.
We know what to do, and there are business opportunities,
but we gotta get smarter about accounting for the real cost.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly, and because I want everybody
to experience some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the plant power meal planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time, we're offering
$10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRhealth at checkout.
This is life changing stuff, people,
for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promocode RRhealth for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
How do you think about effective activism?
You know, on the one hand, activism takes the form of,
you know, a more radical shape, protesting,
extinction rebellion, young people angry in the streets.
And then on the other end of that spectrum
is consensus building or working within systems
to create change with the powers and the corporations
that be like over your many years of being immersed
in this world and trying to solve these very big problems.
What have you learned about what works, what doesn't work?
The world has progressed over the ages one way or another,
because individuals see what others do not.
And then share the view.
Imagine if astronauts came back from the sky
and didn't tell us what they saw,
if they didn't really cause us to see
with a different perspective.
That's what we need right now, to be able to see ourselves
with a different perspective,
to know that the world around us is crumbling.
The natural systems that keep us alive
are in serious trouble.
And knowing that,
how could you not want to do everything you can
to save yourself, to save the people you care about,
to save the whole human culture,
that in a sense we should care about art, music,
all that we've accomplished, isn't it worth saving?
And to do that, we might have to change
some of what we've been doing in the past
that has gotten us to the edge of this precarious cliff,
that if we continue doing what we have been doing,
that seemed okay at the time.
We didn't know. And so we kept doing cutting trees.
We kept taking whales, taking fish out of the ocean,
going to Antarctica of all places,
with taking large quantities of the cornerstone krill
out of the system, just as we had previously taken seals
and penguins and whales, now taking fish and krill,
like when are we going to learn respect for and care
for the systems that underpin our existence
like first and foremost.
I heard Barack Obama once said, "Our highest priority
must be to keep the world safe for our children."
He was thinking guns and things when he made that statement.
But it works in a broader context too,
keeping the world safe for ourselves
and for those who follow, has to be at this point,
this precarious point, climate scientists say 10 years,
it will make or break,
whether we stay within safe temperature limits
through what we do or not because of what we fail to do.
But we're right on the edge.
Why isn't everybody focused on this
as a matter of extreme urgency?
And look, okay, we can't just leave it to governments
because they're all over the place.
Some are really moving strongly in the right direction,
others not so much.
But we as participants in this, that's our lives.
That's what they're talking about
when they're talking climate.
We can take decisions.
And if enough of us take decisions,
we can transcend the laws, speed up the process.
You don't have to have a law
saying, "Stop smoking" to stop smoking.
You can just do it.
You don't have to have a law saying,
"You know, you might want to rethink that halibut
that's on your plate when the next time you order"
to understand the carbon is being released
into the atmosphere when you take it out of the ocean,
and the system that captures carbon is being diminished,
when you remove wild animals out of the system,
the nutrients they put back in,
this closely knit give and take that makes earth habitable
on the land and certainly in the ocean.
But we have been less ready to see what should be obvious,
that the ocean and life in the ocean is critical to climate,
critical to the chemistry of the planet,
is critical to you and me, and maybe,
all right, it might seem like a sacrifice
to give up tuna fish sandwiches for a while, maybe forever,
but you're doing one thing, if everybody kind of gets that,
"Oh, well, carbon, climate, tuna, carbon, climate, whales,
carbon, climate, me, I, the decisions I make."
If enough people start moving in the right direction,
we'll get there.
That governments alone can't do it.
People alone, probably the best chance we have,
but they can't do it without some reinforcement
from the government that at least doesn't penalize you
for doing the right thing
and should reward people for doing the right thing.
Right now we're encouraging through subsidies
a lot of wrong behavior,
whether it's through industrial agriculture
or industrial fishing, or a lot of other things,
including continuing to subsidize
the oil and gas industry and coal.
It's a bottom up and top down thing.
I mean, I think, you mentioned saying no to the tuna
and the halibut, we can issue animal products.
We can say no to single use plastics.
We can choose to vote with our dollars
with the companies that we patronize
that are practicing sustainable, conscious methods.
But I think for a lot of people,
there is a sense of powerlessness or an overwhelm,
the existential crisis that looms, it's just so large,
and what could I possibly do?
And we hear about this term climate anxiety, so-
We should have climate anxiety.
Well, we should, of course, but we shouldn't allow that
to paralyze us, right?
So, other than the things I just mentioned
and that you've talked about,
like when someone comes to you,
as sure they do all the time, Sylvia, and says,
"I'm inspired by your example, I want to get involved,
but I don't know how to do it.
Like tell me what to do or where can I plug into this
where I can have the most impact in my daily life?"
Again, I've thought about this quite a lot.
And you can look around for some short answers to that.
There's a little book about 50 things you can do
to save the ocean.
It's a winner, illustrated by Jim Toomey,
the artist who does "Sherman's Lagoon."
The big shark is the cartoon hero.
David Helvarg is the author.
I say, nobody can tell you, whoever you are,
what you can do better
than that person you see in the mirror can tell you.
Look in the mirror,
ask yourself the question you're asking me,
ask who are you that person in the mirror?
What do you do well? Are you good with music?
Do you have a way with kids?
Are you an artist? Are you a scientist?
Are you..? Whatever you are, you have power.
And you might think that one person
in the midst of the nearly 8 billion of us there are,
is trivial and can't make a difference.
But when you look at history, even today,
there are individual who didn't expect to be leaders,
but they started something.
They took an action that they cared about,
and the word spread and they were the beginners,
beginners, but they joined with others.
One plus one equals two, equals four, equals, you know,
it can magnify, or even if it doesn't,
what you do based on what you know does make a difference.
It does.
And it makes a difference that you don't do something,
every bit as much as when you do something positive.
If you think, "Well, it's hopeless.
I'll just joy myself for the rest of life that I've got.
I'll let the kids figure it out for themselves
or somebody else will do it," you're part of the problem.
You are, because you're just coasting on the good-will
and the good behavior of others.
If you really wanna make a difference,
then listen up, look at what the problems are,
find a piece of that great array of things that worry you,
give you anxiety and say, "I can fix this.
I can do that.
I worry about the plastics that are choking the ocean."
So get out there and pick some of it up
and look at your life and determine what you generate
and try to do better about what you throw away,
and make yourself an example.
And you don't have to celebrate it or make a big deal of it.
But it's amazing, when kids see adults careless
and throwing things away out the window of a car,
they think it's okay.
And so they'll continue to do that.
You know, be an example,
whether it's quiet or with a megaphone,
try to find that thing that resonates with you
and go for it.
I see that happening all over the world
with kids in particular, because why?
They're armed with knowledge that did not
and even could not exist when I was a child,
and they're worried, or they're inspired, or both,
but they're not gonna to just sit back
and allow the world to collapse around them,
or maybe some will.
And I feel sorry for them
because we have to double down and do more
for those who aren't doing what they can.
If they just pick themselves up and get busy, and I...
You've seen societies do this in times of urgency,
whether it's after a storm,
communities come together and they work together
in ways they did not work together before.
We're doing it now with COVID-19.
When we're threatened with a common enemy,
we get together for the common cause.
We need to realize that the fabric of life
that keeps us alive is really getting shredded.
Whatever you can do to restore health to wild places,
wild things, do it in your backyard.
Okay, so you've got a big, beautiful lawn,
or even a tiny little lawn,
think about planting wildflowers,
think of dandelion as your allies, not your enemies,
because they are friendly to bees,
and bees are friendly to pollination that keeps us alive,
holds the world together.
You know, just look at the world with a fresh,
give the world rush look.
Think about looking back on the 21st century
from the next century, or even in 10 years,
what can you do between now and 2030
that will move us in the right direction?
Oh my goodness. There's so many things.
I have never thought of myself
as one who would be characterized as an activist.
I'm a scientist.
I'm a little kid with oversized curiosity.
I wanna know how the world works.
I wanna know everything about everything.
It's what kids start doing, and I never quite stopped.
And I love sharing the view,
which is one of the things more scientists
should be inclined to do.
And a lot of them are getting out of their shell
and becoming more vocal about,
look at this, look what I've discovered!
Don't you wanna go out and find something on your own
or share with me, the joy of putting the pieces together
to see a new concept?
That's how human civilization has been prospering.
And if I can have even a small part in that,
then, okay, call me an activist.
But I think of myself more as an educator,
as a scientist who wants to get others to see what I see.
It's something that began with just pure awe and wonder
as a very young girl, falling in love with the ocean
and wanting to explore and learn as much as possible.
You could have never imagined that the planet would tip
to such an extent where it would compel you
to have to take a certain kind of stand
and become this activist,
because, essentially, you're a botanist and an oceanographer
and somebody who just loves these-
I've been privileged, I realized to see things
that others have not to be able
to spend days, nights, weeks underwater,
getting to know individuals,
mindful that Jane Goodall spent years
getting to know one species very well
and transform the way we think about
not just our fellow primates and one another,
but really caused us to think about life generally.
We haven't had such a great kind of access
to creatures in the sea, except to some extent
in captive circumstances, in aquariums,
those who get to know fish that have lived in an aquarium
for 30 years, get to understand that these are creatures
with not like some of the creatures that we farm
that we take to market in a year or two,
that a grouper may be 30 years old,
or a halibut could be 80 years old
before it comes to your plate and you can carve it up
and dine on it and it's gone in 20 minutes.
Or tuna as similarly.
Takes a lot to make a tuna,
a lot of groceries to make these creatures.
But you, you don't know that when you see it at the market,
all wrapped up in a nice little package
or nicely prepared in a restaurant.
We need to be able to ask those questions:
Where did this come from?
How long did it take to make a lobster
that we dine on in a few minutes?
Or what part of the world did it come from?
What's the carbon signature in terms of transportation
for an Australian lobster that is winding up in Chicago?
It's interesting that you bring up Jane Goodall,
in reflecting on your life and your work and your legacy,
I can't help but draw the comparison to her work,
and there are so many parallels,
not the least of which is this shared sense of hopefulness.
Like she just has this book that just came out,
"The Book of Hope," which I read.
And I see that very kind of strain
flowing through everything that you do.
Like you have that same sensibility.
And then above and beyond that both being people
who created this bridge of empathy to the living world
in a way that not only broke glass ceilings,
but also really fascinated people all over the world.
Of course, Jane with primates
and yourself with helping us to better understand
the individuality of these living creatures
underneath this surface.
So talk a little bit about how that developed
through your various underwater explorations
and the TEKTITE-II, and all the things
that you kind of experienced in your younger years
that helped you realize something that prior to that
science hadn't really reckoned with or acknowledged.
Well, the parallel between Jane Goodall and myself
probably starts with our mothers. (chuckles)
Fathers too, but Jane speaks so lovingly
about how her mother shaped her ethic
and allowed her to explore as a girl
and later going with her to Africa
when she started out as a young scientist.
Well, my mother never had the opportunity to go with me
to share explorations, but she shaped the ethic early on,
the respect for life, all life.
She was the person in our neighborhood
to whom an injured bird or an abandoned baby squirrel,
any creature was brought to nurse back to health
and release back to the wild.
And I think it was that atmosphere of caring
that just I absorbed right as part of my being.
And I can't identify a specific moment,
but I do remember being on a beach in New Jersey,
a little kid, and being entrenched with horseshoe crabs,
these big craggy creatures
whose heritage started long before there were dinosaurs-
Yeah, back 300 million years old, right?
300 million years old?
Yeah, even more than that. But yeah.
And they're still with us, at least they're four species,
three in Asia, one, maybe some slight variations
on the theme up and down the Atlantic coast.
And I thought they were just magnificent.
Never occurred to me to be afraid of them
until adults came by and said, "Hey, kid,
watch out that spiky tail they're poisonous!"
And I just looked at them as if they were crazy.
'Cause I knew better.
I was a little kid, but I knew more than those grownups knew
about that beautiful animal.
I could imagine myself crawling on the beach.
And my first thought when I saw them was
they're out of the water.
They belong in the ocean.
I kept putting them back in the ocean,
and then they crawler back again, of course. (chuckling)
But anyway, because I was there when they come on the shore,
they're there to lay their eggs, which forms the basis
of one of the longest ecosystems on earth
with birds that fly from one polar region to the other,
but stop off along the way to get fat
on the eggs of horseshoe crabs.
Yeah, I grew up going to Rehoboth Beach and Ocean City
along that seaboard, and remember very well those creatures,
'cause for people that don't know, I mean they're very large
and quite striking when you see them on the beach,
and as a child, you feel compelled to pick it up
and examine it and just go,
"I've never seen anything like this!"
I mean they are dinosaurs.
Yes!
Kids are not naturally afraid of creatures
and they don't naturally want to kill them.
We teach them not only to be afraid,
we also teach them it's that killing is good.
We celebrate the killing of things.
And yes, my father and uncles would go out hunting
and bring back wild birds.
But I could never imagine doing that myself, and I never...
You know, since then, one of my uncles was a market hunter,
literally, used to take wild birds, ducks and geese,
by the truckload to market.
That was the way of life early in the 20th century even.
We don't that to wild birds in the 21st century, mostly.
I mean, not for commercial markets, mostly.
There's some exceptions, but mostly we don't.
But we do that, we continue to do it with ocean wildlife.
And that's the thing that we ought no better.
You can see, we can learn from the past
and we have to speed up learning from the past,
what works, what doesn't,
and how to find a place for ourselves
within the natural systems that sustain us.
And Jane has, I don't know
when he started just eating animals,
eating plants, not animals, but at an early age, I gather.
And so when people talk about food security,
we've gotta kill a lot of things for food security,
she'll look at them and I look at them and say,
well, look at the numbers.
It's actually the current part of civilization that is odd.
Throughout most of our history,
we have been sustained mostly by plants.
Now we have increasingly taken an animal based diet
or made a celebration of eating animals,
that this is a good thing.
But now that we can really use our intelligence
and look at the numbers,
going forward, we can't continue to do this.
At least not at the current level,
there aren't enough fish in the sea,
not enough land to support the animals,
to be able to even keep up with the current population,
let alone those going forward in the future.
So anyway, part of this is logic,
part of it is empathy for life,
but it's just word, at a turning point, I think,
in terms of how we're are going to feed ourselves
deliciously and nutritiously and sustainably in the future.
Yeah, there's exciting solutions afoot here though.
I think that the plant-based movement has really caught on
and has gone mainstream in a certain way.
I think it's here to stay,
and people are starting to wake up and realize that-
Just imagine if you go to banquets
and instead of having a vegetarian option,
you have a vegetarian menu with a meat option,
just flip it around.
Right. Well, it should be that way.
And certainly, you know, I read some news articles
that at COP26, there was all kinds of animal products
on the menu at all of these events,
which just seems to me to be insane
when you're at this climate conference
to address these, you know, problems.
Like, you know, when I hear that, it's hard for me
to hold onto that hopefulness when I see stuff like that,
that seems like such low hanging fruit and obvious,
symbolic, of course, but important nonetheless.
Well, I can look to National Geographic,
I think the last time they had their big annual banket,
it was vegetarian based when you could get some meat
if you wanted to, but they did
just what I've been suggesting here.
That was a while ago because we haven't had
big celebration recently because of the COVID crisis,
but there are institutions that are heading
in the right direction.
Anyway.
But I think it's,
yeah, to just to put a pin on that,
I think there is a human kind of inclination
to sit back and just trust that somebody's gonna innovate
our way out of this.
And I think that shirks own personal responsibility
and yes, there are amazing entrepreneurs and scientists
who are figuring out new ways of harvesting food
and all kinds of crazy stuff on the horizon near and far,
and that's fantastic, but I think it's still incumbent
upon all of us to do what we can in our daily lives.
It's one of those things that anybody can do,
do your part, think differently about your carbon intake,
where it comes from.
And some of those things are not really explored
in great detail in this book
where I tried to reflect on the ocean,
why it matters to everyone everywhere all the time.
But one of the things I did, you're asking about,
how you do explore the oceans here in the 21st century,
when we can go to the moon
and we're sending things up to Mars
to gather information and send it back to earth.
Why do we know so little about the ocean?
And what do we know? What are we doing?
So I love the fact that we're beginning
to put little weather stations
out in the ocean, monitoring stations.
It's baffling to me that it has taken us so long,
but the knowledge that we're getting back
about being able to measure currents in the deep sea
with these little devices known as Argo floats
and sharing information.
One of the ways that nations are cooperating
around the world is with environmental data sharing.
We do it with weather and now doing it with knowledge
about the ocean, which all ties together.
And to be able to imagine a time when you might be able
to go to Hertz or Avis and rent a submarine for the day.
Right.
(both chuckling)
I know that's your big ambition.
Let's talk about submarines!
I mean, submarines is a big part of your whole thing.
I mean, you actually actually have a whole company
that builds these submarines.
That's my daughter's enterprise, daughter and son-in-law.
But you started over.
Yeah, I did, but it wasn't the first time.
The first time I teamed up with engineers
was actually after I used the JIM suit,
this diving suit that looks like an astronaut suit,
or the Michelin man,
and went down to 400 meters off the coast of Hawaii
and walked around two and a half hours,
mindful that it was about the same length of time
that Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong walked on the Moon,
but they didn't see anything live except each other.
I saw this amazing, just this kaleidoscope of creatures,
and it was dark.
I could just barely see up from down,
like the faintest gray up and deepest, dark black below.
But these creatures, including bamboo coral,
that flash with this amazing firefly kind of light,
well, actually like a blue light,
fireflies tend to be golden in their color,
but in the ocean, this blue fire is just so amazing.
And like 90% of the creatures in the deep sea,
or even in shallow water at night,
you can see bioluminescence almost everywhere.
Yeah, the bioluminescence thing is unbelievable.
I mean, that was so you're at like 1,280 feet,
still the deepest that any woman has ever gone, correct?
To this day.
Putting your eyes on something that no human being
had ever seen up close and personal ever before.
I mean, it was also this great age of exploration, right?
You talk about when you went on that initial
six-week expedition with the 70 men,
the mandate was to explore.
Right, exactly.
You're here to explore. This is what human beings do.
And there was that era of NASA and space exploration
and oceanic exploration that marked a very special time
that is kind of a bygone era, like we don't value that-
Oh, but it isn't. It really is not.
When you think what we have learned
in the past half century, which some people say
the great eight era of exploration was like in the 1700,
the 15, 16, 1700s, maybe tiptoeing into the 1800s,
with a Challenger expedition
that for the first time really circumnavigated the world
with a mission of exploration.
But when you think it isn't just the skies above
where our mandate is to go explore.
Now we know what we could not know before,
and every new discovery leads to new discoveries
in a much deeper and even more meaningful way.
Like the diversity of life, we once were really focused
on species that if you had of anything,
like the Endangered Species Act, well, okay, you know,
as long as you've got a viable population
and basically a small population would do,
well, now we understand that doesn't cut it.
It really doesn't.
Species all by themselves, and the fact
that the ocean has more diversity of life
and going beyond species,
looking at the main divisions of life,
like the 30 or so great conduits of life, kinds of life,
they're all out there in the ocean, in the book,
"The Ocean Odyssey," we celebrate that diversity
with something really kind of special,
National Geographic figured out
how to take a four double page what's eight pages,
it's four pages that you fold out both sides.
And there is the kind of the history of life on Earth
in full living color. (laughs)
Some of these divisions of life
have not previously been discovered.
This is here. Yeah.
Until my time on the earth,
like the whole, not only the kingdom,
but this great category called Archaea,
that now we know are associated with the manganese nodules
in the deep sea, they're associated with hydrothermal vents.
They look like bacteria,
but they're as different from bacteria
as elephants are from ferns.
I mean, they're really different.
Or I should say fungi, because it's in a different kingdom.
So they occur in us, in the digestive systems of cows.
And they're in the water column.
We didn't even know they existed
until discovered in the late 1970s
associated with hydrothermal vents offshore from Galapagos
two miles beneath the surface.
Now we know they're everywhere. (laughs)
Kind of everywhere.
And what else is out there?
The organism that generates
maybe as much as 20% of the oxygen in the atmosphere,
prochlorococcus, a nerdy word,
but kids can master words like poinsettia and Lollapalooza,
they ought to be able to articulate prochlorococcus.
It's fancy sounding, but anyway.
These are little green Bluegreen bacteria that have existed
almost among the earliest photosynthesizers on the planet.
So spanning like more than 2 billion years,
and they're still with us,
and they're doing the heavy lifting,
capturing carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere,
generating oxygen, providing the basis along with diatoms.
And coccolithophores, another nice name
that you should learn, call them coccos if you want,
but coccolithophores, what's wrong with that?
And other or organisms that are doing this amazing function
that keeps us alive.
We didn't even know prochlorococcus existed until 1986.
And it was on an expedition
in some of the clearest ocean water on the planet,
off Bermuda, in the Sargasso sea,
Penny Chisholm, an MIT scientist with her colleagues
used a new technique for looking at chlorophyll,
looking at microorganisms in the water column.
And they found this minute creatures,
it's thought to be perhaps the smallest cell.
it is tiny, but there are a lot of them.
And they're throughout the tropical and temperate waters
right down to the waters in polar seas,
and variations on the theme.
It's not just one kind of prochlorococcus,
but together this family of microbes
making our existence possible.
And who knows prochlorococcus?
A few crazy scientists.
But we need to celebrate it.
We celebrate it in the book.
We hope everybody will get on word and say,
"Thank you and keep the chemistry of the ocean
at a level that is favorable to them."
But as we warm the planet, as we acidify the ocean,
as we put toxic materials and exotic things in the ocean,
there'll be winners and losers.
And I hope prochlorococcus is among the winners,
because overall there are estimates
that the level of phytoplankton in the ocean is on decline,
perhaps by as much as 40% since 1950s.
40%.
So, don't despair, (chuckles)
realize that they're mostly still out there.
If we change our behavior,
we can shift in a direction more favorable,
not just to prochlorococcus perhaps,
but we know that we can do things
that are more favorable to us.
So the book "Ocean: A Global Odyssey,"
I mean, it's a remarkable and beautiful book,
that's very encyclopedic in its scope.
It captures the majesty of the ocean.
It addresses the problems that we have,
but it's really kind of a celebration.
And it's a sort of choose your own adventure.
I mean, you can open up to any page
and go down a rabbit hole of one particular aspect
of ocean life.
But I suppose the question is like, why this book now?
Like what inspired you to do,
you've written like 20 books over the years,
what is it about this project
that you felt compelled to express now?
Now the first ocean atlas
that I did for National Geographic was about 30 years ago.
And then I did another one.
When I did that, I said "Before the anchors dry,
we'll have to do another one
because we've learned so much so fast,"
and sorry, it wasn't quite that long ago,
but it was a while ago,
I can't remember the actual publication date,
but what I said was absolutely true
that we kept learning new things
that put the book out of date.
And I said, we have to do another one.
The next one I did was published in 2008.
And I said the same thing, we're learning so much so fast.
We're going to have to start keeping notes
on the next one.
So this book is really the distillation
of previous attempts to size up what we now know,
and to anticipate what we don't know,
and to encourage people to at least get up to speed
with what is now out there,
and to enjoy this greatest era of exploration
and do their best to keep up with it.
That this is like a baseline of what we now know,
something we can look back on in 10 years, like 2030,
and say, all right, how did we do? Where are we?
Here's what we knew back in 2021.
And there was a call in at that time, the next 10 years,
the most important, the next 10,000 years.
This mapping endeavor, this era of exploration
that now nations are coming together,
the decade of ocean research, we're now just embarking
on this concerted effort to answer these questions
and put things in perspective.
And I did not undertake this all by myself,
you know, had a team of people working
at National Geographic to gather information.
"Had you seen this?" or "Had you checked out that?"
or "How about this?" or "Had you talked with so and so?"
And their voices of those others are in there,
and several dozen visionaries, champions
who are not only looking at the state of knowledge
and are enhancing it with their work,
but are also a number of the individuals, the heroes
that are celebrated there, are doing something about it,
trying to safeguard the ocean, safeguard the earth,
armed with unprecedented knowledge,
but also understanding the precautionary principle,
given the unknowns, why would we dare exploit places
that we have not yet explored like the deep sea?
How can we possibly in good conscience
go out in the high seas and just rip holes
through those tightly knit communities of life
because we can, just because we can,
and because they're subsidized, we can,
and there's a market for it, we can?
No, we should look ourselves in the mirror and say,
we've gotta stop this.
We have to use whatever power of the marketplace of choice,
of influence to just do everything we can
to embrace the remaining natural wild places, land and sea,
and to safeguard them early and understand why we need them
and they need us to really reverse the trend of decline,
while we still have time.
What percentage of the ocean is currently
under some level of protection?
It's very small, I know.
(indistinct) about 15%.
15? That's actually higher than I thought.
No.
Well, it's beginning to scale up.
Not long ago, it was maybe 12%.
So we're getting a little bit better,
but we need to do it scaling up and speeding up.
Identify places here in California, in your backyard,
you can make your backyard better.
Even if you're already doing a pretty good job
of planting wildflowers and wild plants
and seeing how much of the land in your community,
in your city needs to be paved over.
Can we release rivers?
There's a move now to, I dunno what to call it,
daylighting rivers that are now in culverts
to be a better source of absorbing rain when it falls,
instead of letting it run off and causing problems
in the ocean and flooding
that is harming our infrastructure.
Things that are now armed with these new technologies,
GIS technologies, we can look high in the sky
and bore down into the ground itself
and find out what are the actions we can take
that for me personally, and for my community,
for my country, for the world will make it a better place?
That we can, you know...
Individuals are stepping up and planting milkweed,
so the migrating Monarch butterflies
can have their sustenance back.
We've taken away their breakfast, lunch, and dinner,
and their numbers have been dropping precipitously
as our numbers have increased.
And if we want to have a world with Monarchs and birds
and coral reefs and the things that we aesthetic value,
we know what to do.
We need to make life better for them.
And we can do it one backyard
or one community garden at a time,
but we don't have time to waste.
No.
You you've mentioned a couple times, this 10 year window,
That is really this crucial period of time
in which we have to act and start to, or, you know,
really turn this thing around.
You also have this initiative, the 30 by 30 initiative,
so by 2030 to protect 30%.
So, tell me about that.
To further respond to your question,
the real number for ocean protection is about 3%,
a little less than 3%.
And that means 97% is open for fishing of various sorts,
including this half the world open
for large scale industrial fishing, half of the world.
That's 60% of the ocean. Well, of the high seas.
And then within national waters altogether,
97% is open for taking.
And drilling is done in a large portion of this.
Obviously, there are actions now being taken,
but mining, opening up the deep sea and the high seas
or in coastal waters for mining
is such a mistake at this point in time,
when we see decline all around us
and continuing the large scale extraction of wildlife.
It's perverse. We need to protect wildlife.
We gotta protect the birds, gotta protect the trees.
But what about protecting the fish
instead of eating them all?
If you have to, if it's your sustenance, okay.
But if you're just taking them, because it's fun,
the joy of killing something,
or because you're using fish for money,
and again, I take it that there are coastal communities
and island countries that have this habit
of cutting their trees to sell for lumber.
And we're beginning to see alarm
and people coming, stepping up and say,
"I'm gonna pay you not to kill the trees,"
because everybody benefits from having the trees.
So far, there hasn't been much in the way of those who say,
"Stop killing the fish."
Everybody needs the fish, all of us benefit
from having them capturing the carbon,
maintaining wild systems.
The fabric of life is at risk because of what we're doing
on a industrial scale to ocean wildlife.
Give them a break. No, it's beginning.
But I feel sometimes as if I'm regarded as a crazy person,
because I say such things,
it's just because I see it so clearly.
I can't not share the view.
Yeah.
Well, I think the world
is catching up to you, Sylvia, finally.
I'm hopeful about that. I know you are.
You're so vital, you have such good energy
and so much of it, and at your age,
like how do you keep that battery powered?
You know, people are discriminated against one another
for various reasons.
You're too tall. You're too short.
You're too fat. You're too thin.
You're this color. You're that color.
Ageism is another one.
People look at me and they say, "You're too old."
Used to be, "You're too young, you can't do that."
Or "You're a girl, you can't do that."
I say, it's mostly what you think you can do.
Of course, there are limitations that if you're sick
or you have problems with walking or whatever, but.
you should be allowed to define what your limits are
instead of having them defined for you.
A hundred percent!
I mean, I think a big piece of it, if I could be so bold,
and this is projecting, is that you have this thing
that you feel so strongly about,
that you're so passionate about,
it's work that has no end.
There is a sense of responsibility and a calling
in service to something greater than yourself.
And I think there's something about that equation
and the people that I know that kind of live in that space
seem to be, you know, much more vital
through their later years
than other people that I know in my life.
Yeah, I can't stand the thought that people feel bored.
I wanna say to everyone who says "I'm bored."
Okay, I'll take your time. I'd love to have your time.
I'll use it.
(Rich laughs)
Give it to me! You don't know what to do with yourself.
There's so many ways to go, the books I yet read,
they're sitting there taunting me, "read me, read me!"
Places I haven't been, "Come see me!"
Where do you want to go?
What is ne what's on the horizon?
Or what gets you excited in terms of projects
for the future?
Well, I haven't seen all of the Hope Spots personally yet.
The deep sea beckons always, everywhere,
even in places that you think you know,
like here along the coast of California,
who has been a thousand feet down to see who lives there,
and make the relationship to what is going on above.
During the National Geographic, Goldman Foundation,
NOAA project called Sustainable Seas for five years,
we actually use little submersibles to go on ships
and visit the national marine sanctuaries,
that, quite frankly, don't protect life that's there.
You can fish squid off Monterey, for example,
and sport fishing is encouraged
in most of the marine sanctuary.
So I consider them managed areas,
helpful, but not all that useful
in terms of real protection.
But, okay, so in Monterey, we had a teacher
who joined the project, learned how to drive
these little one person subs and got his kids,
his high school kids to learn to dive during the year
that we really focused on the California coast.
There was a period when our whole expedition
landed in Monterey.
The kids had been studying methods of assessing the nature
of life down to 80 feet using scuba, doing transect studies,
counting the fish, looking at the animals,
relating it to the kelp forest and the sea otters
and the birds above.
And then their teacher came along as a submarine pilot
and went down not to 80 feet, he went down to 800 feet.
And what he saw: no kelp, no sea otrers, no abalone.
The place was owned by brittle stars and basket stars
and creatures like little shrimp
that were spaced a certain distance apart.
They looked like cars parked on a parking lot.
They were just all lined up on a muddy bottom
that underneath that mud was not just, you know, yuck
filled with creatures like another city
beneath the bottom of the ocean.
And it was like, this is Monterey,
as well as this is Monterey.
And we didn't get down to 8,000 feet,
but that would be another version
of what we think we know is Monterey.
So the opportunity that I really want to seize
and take advantage of this point in time
is to go deeper, stay longer, really get to know
where most of life on earth actually lives
in the dark, below where divers can go.
And I want others to go too.
I want to democratize access to the sea
and be around long enough to see my grandkids out there
just enjoying the view, if you will, and kids everywhere.
This is a time when I think we're going to begin
to see what life on earth is really about.
As we gain access to the...
Hey, when I was a child, there used to be talk about,
hey, maybe the moon is made of green cheese, you know,
let's go find out.
But the idea of actually going to the moon
when I was 10 years old, that was so unrealistic.
The thought now of going down to have kids explore the ocean
seems so unrealistic.
The idea of people making choices, that don't include
what we lump together of seafood seems so unrealistic,
but you know, if you don't aim for something,
you'll never get to that place,
you might stumble on it somehow,
but we need to get to a better place by conscious action.
We know what to do.
And so I'm ready to go.
As long as I can breathe, I'm ready to go.
Well, I can't think of a better way
to land this enterprise, this conversation
than what you just shared with me.
Thank you for that.
It's so eloquently and beautifully stated.
And that is an aspiration that I think we can all inhabit
in our own way.
So I appreciate you so much
and aspire to your level of hopefulness and activism.
And if there's anything I can do to support you,
I just really appreciate you coming here today.
One thing maybe, a last thing is just to,
while you're looking in the mirror,
just imagine that you didn't have the capacity to do that.
Even if you can't see to evaluate the gift of life,
imagine not having that, and why not savor every moment
and value it, enjoy it,
and when you're starting to feel doom and gloom,
just realize that you have the power
that no previous people on earth had,
that's the power of understanding who we are,
where we've come from, where we might go,
the power of knowing that superpower,
I think of it that way, and get up and get going.
And don't think that it's all over.
It isn't until it's over and it's not over.
And what you do can empower the next generation
just as what we have now has been empowered
by the previous one ones, plural, through all time.
We are right at the cutting edge of the latest and greatest
of what all humans have been able to figure out and deliver.
And here we are, lucky us, to savor it.
Lucky us. It's not over.
But it is an important time
and we have to take it seriously.
And we need to be more conscious about our daily actions
and our behaviors, but those are things
that we're all capable of doing.
And we're all empowered to be able
to make positive changes in our lives.
So thank you for setting the tone and blazing the path.
Sylvia, I appreciate you.
The book is beautiful.
It's called "Ocean: A Global Odyssey."
It is a book that is packed
with so much beautiful information
and something you could probably display
on any coffee table.
It's really exquisitely rendered.
So congratulations on the book.
If people want to dive into your world,
literally and figuratively, beyond the book,
can they get involved with Mission Blue,
or like, where do you like to direct people
who wanna learn more about you and contribute?
Absolutely, get involved, support Mission Blue.
We are connected to more than 200 other organizations
that we partner with them,
find an organization that is local or national
or international that somehow strums with your heartstrings.
You say, "I like what they're doing
and let me sign up with them."
And for sure, National Geographic. I fell in love with...
National Geographic, when I was a kid,
was my library and my television, if you will,
before television existed, I could travel the world.
And it's still like that.
Were you the first explorer in residence?
I was number three.
Number three. Wow.
But now they've expanded that whole concept
and are supporting a wonderful network of young explorers
who are just at the beginning of their awakening
to what they can do in places all over the world.
And so it's really exciting to have been a part
of the Explorer program
that is in the DNA of National Geographic,
but to really have them focus on supporting individuals
the way they have come to be since, well, the late 1990s.
I came on board in 1998.
And they've tolerated me ever since.
(Rick laughs)
I think they've done a little bit more than that, Sylvia.
Well, come back and talk to me again sometime, will you?
Appreciate it. Thank you.
Peace.
Likewise.
(light music)